it's part of the overall pattern or
picture we have seen over the last
months that Russia has absolutely lost
the momentum
they have been forced to give up a
territory but we should not
underestimate Russia they still have
capabilities they still have forces and
they also have forces and capabilities
that can strike Ukrainian cities we have
seen the drones we have seen the missile
attacks on Ukrainian cities on on
civilian a critical energy
infrastructure so it shows that Russia
can still inflict a lot of damage on on
Ukraine and do you think the war will
last longer than
Wars are by Nature unpredictable
at some stage most likely this war will
end at the negotiating table but we know
that what Russia and what Ukraine can
achieve around that table is absolutely
linked to the strength on the
battlefield so our responsibilities to
support them uh on the battlefield to
support them with a military support to
ensure that they can achieve
an acceptable outcome of the nation
negotiations we reported yesterday that
Russia has according to a Security
Source flown captured British and
American weapons so enlars Javelin
Stinger missiles to Iran along with cash
140 million euros in cash in return for
these so-called suicide drones
what do you think about that I cannot go
into those details or corporate those
informations what I can say is that what
we see is that Iran is supporting Russia
they have delivered these drones
and and and and and that's that's
actually Iran supporting illegal War by
Russia war of regression against the
Ukraine of course we are concerned when
we see a totalitarian authoritarian
regime as the regime in Iran which is
investing heavily in new missiles and
having the nuclear program that they are
working more and more closely with
Russia that just highlights the danger
of this this war